well
how are you greeting héctor mejía with his
brief informative for today wednesday
august 18 the raiders of las vegas
have teamed up with technology to
verify if fans are vaccinated
before they enter the games inside
the original stadium the team announced that
will use the clicker application to
expedite the verification of those
vaccinated attending home games
the user must download the
application and submit their data
including their vaccination card
identification and take a sophie
after verifying all the data the
application gives them a code  qr
word that will be scanned at the ticket office and
will allow the fan to enter the
stadium without a mask
for his part the colo colo seeks to
encourage residents to get vaccinated with
a new program the
group commissioner wants to offer a card with 100
dollars to at least a thousand people  to get
vaccinated, his proposal would cost
the county $100,000, and so far no consent
has been given.  date on which it would start
and the primary 'dumping' mentoring in
general the decision has been made to
return to virtual education for the
next two weeks after an increase in
cases for food on campus
school directors say that the
measure is  temporary for its part the
school district yes yes this revealed that they
still do not have a number of infections that
would force the district to implement
virtual education and that they are making
these decisions on a case-by-case basis in each
particular school and if they are still looking
for places to get vaccinated there are  several
mobile clinics this week here is a
list of some of them the city of
las vegas will be holding a clinic
today from eight thirty in the morning to one
in the afternoon while the supermarket
cárdenas on the tropicana in and will
hold a clinic from 5  at 8
pm the casino that nery will also be
offering vaccines from 10 am to 5
pm on friday and on saturday vaccines
will be available in the preparat  oria
rangers high school 9-2 pm
for a complete list visit and
starting dotcom
now check out the weather forecast
the belly button of the week looks
pretty sunny with a small
chance of
thunderstorms tonight there are some breezes
coming from the  southwest and
temperatures will approach 100
degrees today have a nice day I'm
hector mejia and this was your brief
informative james in spanish
[Music]